this isn't an Avatar movie the first and
maybe the most obvious reason is that
Avatar the way of water is basically
just an amalgamation of other popular
movies and in particular James Cameron
movies there are tons of story beats and
plot details that seem like they were
pulled directly out of other films for
example one of the main plot details in
the film is that the family is
struggling to survive a sinking ship
just like the main plot of another James
Cameron film Titanic it's also no
coincidence that Kate Winslet appeared
in both movies the imitation story beats
don't stop there though near the
beginning of the film The Sky people
return to Pandora and with their rocket
thrusters they burn the forest where the
Solly family lived killing thousands of
plants and animals in the process
immediately when I saw this it made me
think of the nuclear apocalypse scene
and James Cameron's Terminator 2
Judgment Day there's also a third James
Cameron movie that comes to mind
obviously the film Alien was a big
inspiration because it stars Sigourney
Weaver and Aliens just like Avatar